with the kovat 19 caseloads surging a
new poll this morning shows that
President Trump is trailing in several
key states that he won back in 2016 just
take a look at these numbers presumptive
Democratic nominee Joe Biden is leading
by double digits in Michigan double
digits in Wisconsin and double digits in
Pennsylvania
Biden's also ahead by six points in
Florida and other key states seven
points in Arizona and nine points in
North Carolina leisure Jack now looks at
the president's latest efforts to find
support President Trump heads to
Wisconsin today after traveling to
Arizona earlier this week to address a
packed crowd of students the
back-to-back visits to swing states come
as new polling shows a majority of
voters disapproving of the president's
handling of the corona virus pandemic
and protests calling for police reform
at the White House mr. Trump attempted
to show the nation has turned a corner
by welcoming the polish president the
first foreign leader to visit since the
start of the pandemic thank you very
much and on police reform President
Trump said he supports legislation under
one condition we won't do anything
that's gonna hurt our police the
president claimed that's what Democrats
aim to do after they blocked a GOP
policing bill from moving forward in the
Senate which would have created a
national database of police incidents
involving the use of force set up new
training procedures and put restrictions
on chokeholds the issue is do we matter
we had an opportunity to say you matter
so much we'll stay on this floor for as
long as it takes as many amendments as
it takes for us to get to the issue that
says yes
you matter but we said no today
Democrats argued the bill was inadequate
that is not gonna be about real
consequence and real accountability and
that's what America is demanding the
president also said he plans to sign an
executive order to protect statues
Confederate and otherwise on federal
property as well as other historical
monuments many of the people that are
knocking down these statues don't even
have any idea what the statue is what it
means who it is
when they knocked down the protesters
say it is who the statue celebrate at
the center of the problem you should
remember this is exactly what they are
these were people that killed humans as
property president Trump has not offered
any details about that executive order
and it's unclear what it will do since a
federal act already makes it a crime to
destroy or vandalize veterans monuments
on public property that carries up to
ten years in prison
according to the Washington Post u.s.
marshals have been told to get ready to
protect those monuments across the
country Gale all right we should thank
you very much